There's that song again. Listen, little ones — hear how FULL it sounds now? Birds on every branch, bees in the clover, the pond gone warm. A whole spring's worth of busy. Now, I want to ask you something, and it's the last question of the season: when a big, whole, blooming thing finally arrives... who do you suppose made it grow? Listen carefully. The answer's smaller than you'd think.
Now — this happened on the greenest morning of the whole year. Not the FIRST green morning — you remember THAT one, all mud and grey, one little curl by Shelly's foot. This was the morning the WHOLE Creek had caught up. And it didn't happen by itself. Spring is a thing God grows — but He uses a great many small hands to grow it. Listen —
Old Timber! Old Timber, you have to come SEE — the whole meadow went green OVERNIGHT, it's everywhere, I tried to count it and I ran OUT of numbers!
...That's Bongo. And do you know — for the first time all season, he wasn't running TO anything. He'd come to fetch ME — to go SLOW, and look.
And down at the pond, the whole Creek had gathered in the green. And over hopped Bongo the bear cub, holding ONE leaf like a treasure. He said,
Okay, okay — I KNOW it's just a leaf. But look how LOW I had to get to find the prettiest one. All season I learned that. The good stuff is little, and you find it slow. ...I only stepped on three things getting here. New record.
And in zipped Zippy the hummingbird — but, and you'll notice this, actually LANDING. She squeaked,
Okay — okay. I have been WATCHING the bean Shelly and I planted in the slow race. For WEEKS. Do you know how hard it is for me to watch ONE thing slowly? My whole body wanted to vibrate. But I waited. And — Bongo, it sprouted. The slow thing WORKED.
...The bean's fine, Zippy. You only checked it forty times.
Forty-ONE. But who's counting. ...Me. I'm counting. That's the whole thing I do.
Forty-one's a good number though. I only know up to about... green. After that it's just 'lots.'
And from the big old oak, all bright feathers, swept down Garingo the parrot, who had — and I want it on the record — prepared REMARKS.
BEHOLD! The Creek in its GLORY! Friends, wayfarers, fellow witnesses to the GREENING — I have composed a speech. It is four hours long. ...I shall give you the SHORT version: spring is here. There. The rest was mostly about ME.
...That was the best speech you've ever given, Garingo.
...Because it was the SHORTEST. ...I heard it. I heard the trick in that. ...I shall allow it. The brevity was, I confess, rather magnificent.
And at the edge of it all stood Fern the fawn — not at the edge because she was shy, not anymore, but because she'd brought somebody. She turned, clear and warm, and said —
I noticed something. The new ones came back. ...Maya — come in, it's alright, we're all here. Remember? You used to not know which way the pond was. Now look — you brought the LEAF idea. Tell them.
Hi — hi, everyone. Okay. So — it's still SO weird that you can all talk. I keep waiting to wake up. But, um — Fern showed me how everybody here looks after each other. So I thought, what if we each bring ONE green thing to the pond, and we line them all up, and see how much spring we made? Together?
So one by one, they laid their green things in a row by the water. And as the row grew, so did the story of how each one got there. Listen —
And over from the borderlands, dust still on his quills, came Bramble the hedgehog — the one who travels round and tells tales, who turns up when a season turns. He laid down a sprig and said,
Story I heard once — out toward the borderlands. A fellow planted a whole hillside, walked away, came back in spring expecting bare dirt. Found it green to the top. ...He didn't do that. He only put the seeds DOWN. Something else did the growing. ...That's all. That's the story.
Wait — so the planting guy did the EASY part and the hillside did the hard part? ...That's the best deal I ever heard. I want THAT job.
...Bongo, you already HAVE that job. You stepped on a sprout this morning and it grew anyway.
That's the whole point of the story, Bongo. ...Also that's MY job too. ...We're all on the easy part. Huh.
And splashing up the bank, soaked to the whiskers and grinning, came Rex the otter, dragging a great dripping armful of cress. He gasped —
NEW favorite thing — watercress! No wait — the ROW of green things! No — okay — my new favorite thing is watching everybody pile their stuff up and the pile getting HUGE! ...I learned to slow my happy down so it fits other people. So. I brought a LOT of happy. But — paced. Paced happy.
And then a quick rustling fellow came zigzagging down the path with his cheeks stuffed, stopped, looked at the long green row — and for once in his life, set something down GENTLY. That was Chitter the chipmunk. He said,
Okay — okay — I brought green things, I brought a LOT, but watch — I'm keeping some! See? Some in the pile, some back in my cheeks for ME, and I'm not even scared about it! I used to think keeping ANY was selfish. Turns out I'm allowed a full bowl AND a glad heart. Both! At once! It's the best thing I learned all year.
Chitter, last spring you would've handed me the cheeks too.
I KNOW. I'm a changed chipmunk. ...I still want to give you the cheeks a little. But I'm not GONNA. Growth!
Now the row of green stretched all along the water's edge — leaves and sprigs and curls and cress, a whole crooked green ribbon. And they stood back to look at it. And for a moment, nobody said a word. The prettiest quiet of the whole season.
...Magnificent. Each one different. And not a single one of them HERE three months ago.
And that was Professor Hoot — who'd spent the whole season learning that the more he KNEW, the BIGGER the wonder got. This time, he didn't count the leaves. He just looked. And up the creek, somebody small and gray was kneeling in the mud.
And up the bank knelt Quilla the chinchilla — small and gray and quiet, doing the thing nobody claps for. Bongo padded up, looked down at what she was tending, and said,
Quilla? We're all down at the pond looking at the big green row. Come see! ...Wait. What are you doing way up here all by yourself?
Tending, little bear. Same as every morning. ...See this one? Right here, by my foot. The littlest green thing on the whole bank. I've watered it before the sun every day since the first thaw. Nobody asked me to. Nobody saw. ...A small thing kept faithfully turns into something, in its season.
...The littlest green thing. By your foot. ...Quilla. ...That's — wait. WAIT. That's the SAME one. Shelly! SHELLY — get up here — it's the SAME little curl! From the FIRST morning! It GREW!
And Shelly came — slow as anything, the way she does — and looked a long while at the little plant, taller now, leaves wide open. And she said, soft —
...It's the one I found at first thaw. The size of nothing. Two leaves like little open hands. ...And here it is. Reaching higher than my shell. ...I found it. But I didn't grow it. I just stooped down and said hello.
And I watered it. Quietly. ...But I didn't grow it either, Shelly. I only carried the water. ...Something else did the growing. Every single morning, while I slept, it grew without me.
...I almost crushed this one. Way back at first thaw. I ran right past it, looking for something big. And the whole time, the biggest thing in the whole season was THIS — the littlest green thing, getting tended, getting bigger, the whole time, while I was busy racing.
And I think — I think the saddest way to miss spring is to be so busy looking for the WHOLE thing that you step right over the start of it. ...A whole season grew, right under all of us. And mostly... nobody was watching it. Except Quilla.
And nobody rushed to fix the feeling. They just let it sit there, all of them, in the green. And then Old Timber — that's me — came and sat down slow in the mud beside the little plant, and asked them the one thing I wanted to know. I said —
Friends... look at the whole green Creek. Every leaf of it. ...Now — whose work was it? Who made the spring?
...We all did a little of it. Shelly noticed the first one. Quilla watered it. Bongo learned to look low. Zippy learned to wait. ...But none of us could've MADE one single leaf open. Not even the littlest one. We just... helped.
We planted, and we tended, and we watered. ...But God did the growing. He gave the increase. We just got to be the small hands.
...Huh. So the answer was never WHO was fastest, or who found it FIRST, or who gave the MOST. ...The answer was: we tend, and God grows. ...That's the simplest answer there's ever been. I can't even make it fancier. I TRIED.
...I'll get there. I always do. ...Took me a whole season to walk from one green leaf to a whole green Creek. ...Turns out spring did the same thing. One small road. Tended all the way.
And do you know what they did? They carried that little plant — mud and all — down to the pond, and set it at the head of the long green row. The one that started it all. And the whole Creek stood around it in the warm.
...This is the nicest thing I've ever been part of. And I almost didn't come, that first day. I almost stayed home because I didn't know anybody. ...I'm really glad somebody said come in.
New favorite thing. ...It's not a thing. It's all of you. ...Okay THAT one I'm keeping.
...I have, I confess, ONE more remark. ...A whole Creek, grown from a speck. ...BEHOLD what the small things did. ...That's it. That's the remark. So short! I'm as shocked as you are.
Now, that little plant at the head of the row put me in mind of something. There's a line in the Bible — in a book called First Corinthians, chapter three, verses six and seven — where a man named Paul writes a letter to his friends. They'd been arguing about who was most important.
And Paul tells them to stop counting up who did the most — because the part that really matters, not a one of them did. He put it plain. Paul wrote:
I have planted, Apollos watered; but God gave the increase. So then neither is he that planteth any thing, neither he that watereth; but God that giveth the increase.
...That's us, Old Timber. We planted and we watered. ...And God did the increase.
That's it exactly, Bongo. Shelly stooped down. Quilla carried the water. The whole Creek brought their small green things. And God grew a spring.
So here's the last thing I'll leave you, this whole season long: do your small part, gladly, even the part nobody sees. Plant. Water. Tend. ...And let the growing be God's. It always was.
Until the next breeze brings us together, my friends. It's been a green and growing year. Go gently out there, little ones — and do your small part well.
And from his lecture branch swooped Professor Hoot, the most certain owl in Shiloh Creek. He cleared his throat — and announced,
Professor Hoot here, with a fact that is completely true. You've spent all season watching things grow. So here is a fact about how a tree keeps SCORE of its own growing. Every single year, a tree adds one new ring of wood, just under its bark.
One ring. Every year. So if you ever see a tree stump, you can count the rings and know exactly how many seasons that tree has lived. The clever name for reading those rings is dendrochronology.
What does it mean? It only means tree-time-reading — using the rings to read how old a tree is. A wide ring is a good, wet year. A narrow ring is a hard, dry one.
So a tree is a kind of JOURNAL, children. Every season it ever grew through is written down inside it, ring by ring. The good springs and the hard ones — all kept, all counted, none of them lost.
Which means somewhere in this very wood, a tree is, right now, beginning the ring for THIS spring. The one you all just lived. A fact, true and tested. Good evening.
And out from the reeds came the Mudpuppy brothers — Splish, Splash, and Splosh. Splosh started,
Today on Mudpuppy Minutes, we will explain... why flowers BLOOM in the spring!
Easy. Flowers bloom in spring because they get BORED of being closed. A flower's been shut all winter, and one day it just goes, 'ugh, fine,' and opens up.
AND ALSO — ! It gets WARMER, and the days get LONGER, and the sun wakes the flower up, so it opens to drink the light. ...wait. That sounded almost like a real reason.
Oh no, no — that can't be right, that's too SENSIBLE. No. Flowers bloom because they hear the BEES coming and they want to look nice for company. It's manners. Flowers have the BEST manners.
AND ALSO — every flower keeps a tiny MIRROR! For checking its petals before the bee arrives! You can't host company looking rumpled!
Wait — is it actually just... the sun getting warmer and the days getting longer?
...nah.
Mudpuppies, mudpuppies — we have solved it. Flowers bloom in spring because of MANNERS and tiny MIRRORS. Heave. Ho. ...just like a bell. On a cold rock.
Let's set it right before you drift off, little ones. A flower opens in spring because the days grow longer and the sun grows warmer, and that warmth and light wake it up — so it opens to drink the light in.
Splash had it, fair and square — warmth and light, no manners required. ...Though I will say, a flower full of bees does look awfully pleased with itself.
That's a season, friends. See you next time... somewhere in Shiloh Creek.